5 55 on your friday morning something
that's been driving raiders fans crazy
oh you know parking for those home games
at allegion stadium but here's the deal
the raiders website has great
information
including a detailed map that pinpoints
the 15 entry gates between russell road
and hacienda the east and west side
drop-off locations the rideshare
drop-off and pickup area north of the
stadium as well as the taxi area at
procyon and diablo to the west of
allegiant
then there are the numerous parking lots
several surrounding allegiant with
others as far away as trop and valley
view
as for which to choose from the website
has links to spot hero and parking.com
where you can find and pay for your spot
and that much cheaper no driving option
the regional transportation commission's
game day express
and we've got links to all of the
websites mentioned in the online version
of this story at eight news now when you
click traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone if there is something
driving you crazy my email address
traffic 8 8newsnow.com